so much easier for us to imagine
going forward the problems and all the
ways in which it doesn't work that's
entropy it's harder to imagine the one
or two ways things do work
the way things work are much more
improbable than the way things break
that's again that's the rule of Entry
that's the second law of Thermodynamics
that's never been broken the ways in
which things cannot work and degrade are
far far faster than the few ways that it
can work because things at work are more
improbable part of what we want to be is
we want to be improbable beings another
way we could say like don't be the best
the only is be the most improbable
person possible
[Music]